[Music]
science is changing how and when
families are made women are going to be
able to have both career and family in a
way that we've never seen before new
technologies are transforming IVF
success rates AI allows us to look up
features of the embryo invisible to the
human eye and families are growing up I
tell them no I'm not the grandmother I'm
the mother and they go you're the mother
[Music]
[Music]
my name is dawn Hallett I'm 65 years old
and I'm the mother of Audrey Evelyn and
Hallett Audrey is one year old dawn and
her husband Mike who's 66 a proud first
time parents in Nova Scotia Canada they
married in 1977 and tried for a baby for
decades when we were in our early 30s we
discussed about having a family and then
we went for testing and we found out
that our chances were very slim and 10%
10% chance that we could have a child of
our own attempts to conceive naturally
and to adopt failed so five years ago
dawn turn to IVF and donor eggs for help
I went to a local clinic and they said I
was too old that they wouldn't work with
us in Canada as in America industry
guidelines discourage embryo transfers
to women over 55 who face a higher risk
of prenatal health conditions including
preeclampsia hypertension and diabetes
[Music]
Dawn considered surrogacy
she looked abroad to developing
countries with less restrictive
guidelines in legislation first place we
we went to India our surrogate was
sitting in her doctor's office and India
closed their doors to international
surrogacy we flew to Mexico City and we
tried three times there was with a
surrogate and my husband and she failed
three times international fertility
consultant crystal Travis directed the
couple towards Georgia motherhood one of
the world's least regulated fertility
markets
and one of the few countries that allows
surrogates and donors of eggs and
embryos to be paid I felt that I was
healthy enough that I could carry a baby
if needed to because I exercised my
whole life after medical tests Dawn had
an embryo made with a donor egg and
donor sperm implanted I said to Mike I
said I just don't believe there it's
gonna work anyway so on the 23rd of
December when we got on the 23 December
wait wait wait I went over to the
drugstore and got the cut the actual
pregnancy test yeah I'm the technical
guy so I did the different and basically
I can balance is by the way you're 2 to
3 weeks pregnant yeah and at that point
we're just like okay because you don't
know after you're going I was shocked
and I was shocked totally shocked you
know this is a miracle
the total number of fertility clinics
around the world is estimated to have
increased by almost 70 percent in the
last 10 years
[Music]
the value of the global fertility
industry is predicted to rise from 25
billion dollars today to 41 billion
dollars by 2026
[Music]
many believe there needs to be more
regulation of an increasingly globalised
IVF trade including dr. Daniel Lane a
fertility specialist based in San
Francisco I think that the risks far
outweigh the benefits of being pregnant
at 65
we do not do embryo transfers and anyone
who's above the age of 50 however dr.
Lane is using new technology that will
allow more women to have children later
in life we are definitely seeing an
increase in egg freezing so clearly the
trend is that women are delaying their
childbearing in 2017 the number of women
freezing their own eggs in America
jumped by nearly a quarter in one year
alone
dr. Lane believes this will help some
women balance their careers and families
more effectively in the future now we're
saying you can have that child at 40
using your 28 year old eggs so maybe it
matters that you spend those extra 10
years focused on your career and get to
a point where you feel comfortable
having that baby at 40
there is another technological
development that might accelerate this
trend towards older parents
today dr. Michelle progeny is unveiling
a new artificial intelligence
application at the lane fertility
Institute
embryo assessment is currently done by
an embryologist sitting in front of a
microscope what we do is take microscope
images directly drag and drop them onto
our system and the AI runs over those
images and produces an instantaneous
confidence score the application is
designed to improve the chances of
selecting embryos that will lead to
successful pregnancies our data show you
that we're thirty percent more accurate
in terms of being able to predict the
pregnancy outcome that's what it is
this application is awaiting regulatory
approval in America if it delivers on
its promise it could help make IVF more
accessible is there a way that the
application of this AI will actually
make IVF more affordable if we can get
patients pregnant quicker or in fewer
cycles by virtue of picking the best
embryo then it will be cheaper overall
as the science grows so will the
opportunities for more would-be parents
to start families later than ever before
there will always be decisions to be
made about career and family but the
ability to plan them out is so much
better now than it was even a decade ago
[Music]